today was Thursday we're recording this
Thursday Ju Thursday exciting part I
phone for launch that's not exciting
I went 7:00 a.m. this morning you're
pathetic to the Apple store no not what
the the point in getting I five
phone for what's-what's what's different
with the retinal display what's
different than iPhone three what's the
difference between iPhone 4s bleh it's
awesome
no no that's not a difference okay you
will actually wanna know the difference
so I had two 3G mm-hmm and since then
there's been a 3GS but the display is a
lot better you can read the text way
easier
oh because that's been such a problem
Jeff I remember you've been calling me
up in the middle of night well you know
like Adam I'm calling you on my iPhone
but I wish I knew I was called new cuz I
can't even read this no way MIT that
never happened no it was fine it
is fine did it reason I bought the new
one mmm-hmm the video camera the video
the iPhone 3 didn't have a video camera
3G did not have a video camera it had a
static camera but no video no video so
that's one improvement
yeah and for comedy you know it's
sometimes helpful all right I guess I
can see that um otherwise I would have
stuck with my old one but honestly I'll
say this an entire city block full of
people all needing a phone that also
takes video Nomos those people are just
getting backed off - yeah it's home I
don't I don't get it I don't get it it's
like for me if somebody's gonna put out
something new a new version of something
it better be incredibly
different than it was incredibly
different no it has it has a can
it's got a metal edge the metal edge see
all this you know it's it's
just it's it's that no display you know
what it reminds me and a back facing
camera you know what it reminds me of GI
Joe I took GI Joe or Ninja Turtles the
fact that every every couple months
they'd come out with a new GI Joe or a
new ninja turtle that didn't look really
anything different than one of the other
ones except it was like one of the GI
Joes painted somewhat differently or one
of the GI Joe or one of the Ninja
Turtles it's like oh well instead of a
turtle these are ninja frogs they're
Samurai Ferrar it's kind of like
transformers and gobots
yes it's garbage
instead of costing $5.95 they have to
beg your mom for $200 200 dollars
how much did your camera cost we're
using a camera right here how much did
that cost a grand a grand that is a nice
camera that ruined that ruined my whole
grand scheme he was trying to pull but
still still point is I don't think the
new iPhone is worth it it's totally
worth it Adams dumb I don't I don't
think it's worth it man
and this is why items a bad nerd no
horrible nerd no yeah you like it I'm a
nerd I'm a horrible nerd because I have
the ability to understand the gimmicks
that people are pulling on it's a game
as an awesome device it's it has a
camera that's the only difference
difference but if you hadn't bought a
phone why not get knife on well okay
okay you're right if I had to buy phone
did you so you didn't have a phone you
only had your landline before the iPhone
came out yeah dude
no you had an all I had was a telegraph
machine he had an eye which wasn't
really inconvenient he had an iPhone
this morning when he went to the Apple
store to buy a new iPhone and you know
what the Apple employees are crying for
me whatever whatever it's just sad I
might as well gone in cowboy gear I'm
gonna come out I'm coming out with a new
product mariya America it's called the
rock I even say America it's a rock and
next in next year I'm coming out with a
brand new one it's called rock 2.0 and
it's shiny yeah there you go spend $500
on me it's gotta have multitasking and
folders you know that was just an OS
upgrade but you know whatever whatever
whatever Steven note OS is it's kind of
funny I don't care
[Music]